wirklich nicht
savosa skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute endlich ist es
soweit endlich kommt das epische duell
in fifa 18 luca gegen sebastian der us
kids gegen lupo auf meinen kanal leute
es ist wirklich soweit einzelne bei luca
schon gemacht
leute wir spielen wie gesagt in viel
verachtung den fifa 18 gibt es einige
neuerungen gegenüber den älteren spielen
und zwar gibt es jetzt die dritte
deutsche liga und den dfb-pokal neu da
drinnen es gibt sogenannte schnellen
wechseln kann man einfach so einen
button hätten aufdrücken r2 und dann
macht er im vorschläge wie man ein
wechseln soll und es gibt neuen trick
den eltern die mirabellen nicht können
und jetzt geht s los leute vielfach sind
das locker gegen sebastian spiel zwei
wohlgemerkt
es gab schon ein fluggast kantonen leute
da sind wir jetzt im spiel ich habe mir
keine überraschung für mich ausgelacht
und zwar habe ich gesehen was in dem
spiel vielleicht bisschen probleme
gehabt ein neuer vorbei zu kommen
deswegen spielt neureichen nicht sondern
weist weißt du wer spielt mit
er ist passage perfekten größe einer
73er ist linkes mittelfeld ja egal das
reicht schon wenn es ist ein eher ist
man erst okay nein junge fast überhaupt
keine torwart dabei
man muss wirklich sagen im ersten spiel
hatte ich so unglaublich hochkaräter die
einfach nicht an neuer vorbei gegangen
sind weil der welttorhüter ist und jetzt
also normalerweise sagt meine leute hat
muss groß sein
ich habe mir gedacht 173 ist so gute
größe und wenn ich jetzt verlieren
sollte was muss ich machen denkt die
irgendetwas okay wenn sie jetzt
verlieren solltest dann musst du für den
rest deines lebens egal wann werde ich
fragen zu geben das richtig wie von gott
bin der einzige ich habe die ersten
stocks die junge bruma ist gut man
glaubt ja einfach geil ich kann mir dann
läuft also ich hab noch nie so wirklich
mit einem links mittelfeld als vorrat
gespielt ich habe das schon mal gemacht
und es war gar nicht so geschützt
ich hab' ich hatte mal christa nie ins
tor gestellt
[Musik]
ja
denn ernst das nicht einfach mit einem
ausgerissenen winkel so ich will mal
sehen wie die bremer sich in vorschlägt
kann einfach nichts
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass er hält nun
will sich das sind 9 und alter warum das
warum eigentlich alte alter das ist doch
nicht warten das muss jetzt zweistellig
werden auf gar keinen fall okay leute
jetzt ich wieder in der vorwärtsbewegung
trojan 96 coup sollte aber ich kann das
halte ich richtig behörde hält jetzt
vorwärts dran ist dann ab wir hatten
politiker muss meine abwerfen ja was tue
ich denn in der abwehr und ich soll
nicht überheblich fielmann ist 1
vereinsseite jetzt hier royce
angestellter schuss wichtiger warum
schickt boateng bei mir die ecken es ist
eine krankheit das macht jetzt mit
spielweise da kann es mal nicht trifft
schon mal in 16 nicht schlecht und
der gewinn kann wie kann wer ist dass
müller oder was
wie kann er dann da so frei seien gucke
dann gucken wir mal rauf auf die backe
ich bin auf dem weg zum titel fifa gott
[Musik]
brutal da ist es war das war echt gut
rausgespielt haben aber jetzt habe ich
eine idee aber auf die außen - kein ging
nach draußen jan ist verunsichert ja
wohl versteht einfach zwei zu 233 minute
weil gruber im tor
liga nicht weil sondern obwohl obwohl
jeffrey bruma im tor steht dort wo jetzt
buemi an der a 620 ps der den lochkarten
was nicht wahr sein was das denn für
eine partie um junge wie schaffst es
jedes ding rein zu machen
gruber wehrendorf ski müller ist meine
stunts schuss so andré umdrehen
gleichzeitig wäre drin gesehen jetzt
einmal ihr lasst sie doch einfach nur
die schießen war das ist doch nicht war
doch sowieso hinter dem nicht fest dass
es bedürfe bube das ist junge wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass der ball so
kommt wer war es ich weiß jetzt
ausgewechselt werden und müll leere
hülle aus 30 metern trifft nicht weil
ich spiele jetzt wieder so ein bisschen
meine taktik hier zu ende ein bisschen
ballbesitz brachten kommt
ich gehe mal so nach hinten und denkst
so geiles ding oder denke ich huber ich
muss sagen es ist eine ehrenhafte aktion
von dir einzupacken aber ich glaube da
keinen spaß
eigentlich wollte ich das so als job
macht also boom am anfang also haar und
der kassier anton heuer wieder ein neuer
ist einfach nicht mit dabei ich glaube
ich das ist mein größter spieler ins tor
jetzt wechselte müller kommt überhaupt
den beiden müllers vergleich sehr
offensiv mann gibt es gibt und jawohl
das ist doch nicht war aber kummer und
rechts heute habe ich das angebot
klitschkos haben preuß für belarus kann
auch bisschen hat noch bisschen power
aber so funktioniert dass er zwei
drittel lang ob das ding raus
bruchmüller gut müller cory seit heuer
dann hab ich aber jetzt ist ja jetzt
junge war das wichtig dass das sofa um
einen keil in die luft werde die
entscheidung
und so kann es und will nach dem königs
dabei direkt alexis sanchez ehrenmann
und jungs firma dorfs kilian
ich muss noch schießen das geht nicht
und was macht dazu kommen nein das ist
nicht wahr alter die kann scheint an der
abwehr vorbei geht ist schön macht da
nicht ein hobby hericks und verletzt ich
hab das gefühl deine stimme schießen
1000 mal besser ist wenn er nicht beim
tor ist ist er war echt als auch die
schüsse besser kommen das macht noch
keinen sinn weil es würde bei neuen
direkt sagen komm ich für mich ist das
gar nicht wirklich
[Musik]
gibt ja noch ein entscheidungsspiel